as part of this you did a lot of
fascinating things one of the things you
did you talked about creating synthetic
people meaning uh creating fake
identities what does what does it take
to do that to do that well so your
credit profile is made up of your you
know your your at your name date of
birth your address and you know your
social security number and you know
those are the kind of you know and then
there's other things where you work
that sort of
thing but what people don't realize is
there's so many people out there that
think that the credit bureaus already
know who you are right but the truth is
the first time the credit bureau has
ever heard about you was when you told
them the first time you applied for a
credit card you they created a credit
profile at that moment prior to that
they had no idea so the first time you
apply you give them your your full name
date of birth social security number and
your
address and they create a credit profile
and they say hey no record found of this
person he has no credit nothing probably
got denied well what I realized through
the course of because of eventually I
ended up leaving that one company and I
open my own mortgage
company when I opened that mortgage
company I
was I was on the inside does that make
sense like I wasn't I wasn't just a
broker that was sitting out with
everybody else and would periodically
come in and ask questions or would call
underwriting and but really didn't
understand what was happening and what
exactly what the underwriting guidelines
were now I was actually talking to the
underwriters and you're you're talking
to the um to the owners of The Lending
institutions and the banks and you're
talking to all of the account Executives
and now it wasn't just Eagle lending I
was talking to there were 40 different
account Executives coming in on a weekly
basis is trying to get us to sign up
with their lender M and they're on the
inside telling you coming in showing you
uh programs and saying look if your
borrower is you know
self-employed we don't ask for this or
this we just ask for them to say they're
self-employed like liar loans You'
you've heard the term liar loans okay um
no doc loans where they don't ask for
any documentation if he's got over like
let's say a 700 credit score and he says
he's been a plumber and he works for
himself self then he's got over a 700
credit score he just has to say he's
worked for himself for over two years
and they don't ask any other they don't
ask for any documentation he's got the
money in the bank he's got a 700 credit
score says he's been on the job for two
years he's self-employed we're going to
raise his insurance rate by
1% and and he's got you know that's it
he's he's got the loan so but you start
to you start to know how things work
because I hired a bunch of Brokers to
work underneath me and when they would
get caught
I would get the phone call so I get the
phone call from the owner of a bank or a
lending Institute you know A lender and
that lender says hey Matt we got a
problem I'm like what's up he's like
he's like listen uh we we caught a fake
W2 I'm like what do you what do you mean
yeah your your broker soand so sent us a
file and this person had there's two
fake W2s and we're assuming the pay subs
are fake and I'm like are you serious
how how did you even catch that and they
oh well here's what we did we checked
with
sunbiz.com you know sunbiz.gov which is
the Secretary of State's website that
registers corporations and we checked
and the tax ID number didn't match and I
now I know every W2 has to have a
matching uh tax ID number for whatever
corporation uh issued it so there's a
sequence of checks they do to detect
fraud on different documents like W2s
and then you're slowly learning slowly
yeah exactly what's the process for
detecting I mean I had a pretty good
understanding anyway yeah but so I'm
starting to learn that understanding
yeah so I'm putting these things
together and I remember one time I had a
woman come in and she came in and she
had perfect credit she had like 750
credit scores I mean it was perfect and
she came in and uh one of the Brokers
came in and said hey man he's can I show
you something I was like yeah what's up
he he goes look he said I've got this
This Woman's W2s here I said okay I
looked at him and he goes here's your
credit report and he goes here's the you
know application this is the this is the
social security number I went all right
and he said this is the social security
number on the W2 and I went okay keep in
mind you go to get a car loan or credit
card they never asked for these things
so and he was like and I'm really
shocked he even noticed it I probably
might not have even caught it but he
they were different and I went really
and he goes yeah he said um so I I did
you know she just brought him in you you
know she's here I was like oh bring her
in here so she came in sat down and said
listen here's what we just found and she
was like oh okay you know what I don't
want the loan I I just I go no no no no
I said listen you're getting the loan
you got a 750 credit score like I don't
care what we have to do we're getting
you the loan I just want to know what's
going on how are how did you we how did
you get 750 credit scores under this
social security number when clearly this
is your real social security number
you've been working for this company for
10 years and your credit profile says
it's only like 3 years old MH and I was
like what happened and what she told me
she did was she had been she went
through a divorce she had been married
for 10 years used her husband's I mean
his surname for 10 years so she has no
credit under her maiden name MH but when
they got divorced she switched to her
maiden
name um because when she pulled tried to
get anything in her in her um husband's
surname it was denied bad credit
so he had bad credit their credit went
bad so he switched to her she switched
to her name and a friend told her if she
needed to get her electric or anything
turned on she could use her name and use
her daughter's or son's social security
number which was like a four-year-old
kid y so she used that and it went
through she had to put a deposit down
but it went through at least wasn't
denied so that went through then she
went and she applied for an apartment
with that m
sure enough it went through she had no
credit but they said you don't have bad
credit so she said once she moved into
the apartment she then started getting
these pre-approved credit cards so she
she but I knew I had applied there using
my son's social security number let's
say so she started filling those out and
sure enough she got a credit card and
then she got two and then she got a
pre-approval from Ford Motor Credit she
went and got herself a new car got
approved she'd been making the payments
ever since she has 750 credit credit
score she thought she'd try her hand at
buying a house in his name in his social
security number
and we caught it and she got a house in
that name we we closed it I just was
like wow like this is great can I ask
you a question about that because it
seems like she's able to pay for
everything right so while this is highly
illegal is it unethical is it
like it's it's unethical in that it's
messing with the system on which a lot
of people
rely but it feels like there's some
aspect of the system that's broken in
that it doesn't give people like her a
second chance she could have claimed
bankruptcy and then two years later
listen two years out of bankruptcy you
can go into Bank of America and get a
conventional mortgage assuming you have
perfect credit outside the bankruptcy
you have the down payment you make
enough money there's a whole bunch of
you know a bunch of uh underwriting
guidelines you have to meet but that's
possible but you're right for instance
she wasn't getting an apartment using
with her bad credit she wasn't getting
her utilities turned on she wasn't
getting any of those things done so
getting your life back on track is just
harder it's extremely hard so there's a
temptation to take the shortcut and the
shortcut is often going to be illegal
right and she stumbled into it but she
basically explained it to me and I I
mean I don't think she had walked out of
the of my brokerage office before I went
and I just started making up you know
names and I think I went went and into
our file cabinet and grabbed some
people's uh 1040s which we had you
know their tax returns and looked up
children's Social Security numbers and
just grabbed some random kid Social
Security numbers and their name and went
and pulled them and sure you know but I
changed their date of birth to be an
adult pulled it and sure enough it came
up no file found you know it didn't say
fraud alert or fraud or anything didn't
say mismatch this mismatch that didn't
say anything it just said you know no
file found
well
then we went and we pulled applied for a
couple credit cards using a child social
security number and then we went and
pulled Our Own Credit Report and sure
enough it didn't say no no file found it
just said that there had been two
inquiries applying for credit cards so I
was like wow like that's a credit
profile so that turns into
me going to Social Security
and calling or calling Social Security
and trying to get them to issue me
Social Security numbers to adults that
had never had a social security number
issued to them I need to get Social
Security number to give me a clean
social security number but I called up
and of course you know I'm a novice I
don't really know what I'm doing so I
call up and I say hey uh yeah I was I'm
uh never had a Social Security Number
issue and they were like how old are you
and I was like I'm 31 years old you know
and they were yeah that's not possible
do you have a driver's license uh yeah
you have a bank account yeah you have a
Social Security number uh bring your
driver's license in and we'll we'll pull
it up okay well that's not going to
happen hang up call back hi um my
son is 7 years old or three years old
and he he never had a social security
number issued oh okay was he born in a
hospital yes well he has one he has one
go ahead and uh get your son come in
here
no I'm not doing that hang up call back
so I called back probably 10
times and
eventually uh someone said I I kept
altering it kept altering what I was
saying till I got to the point where I
was
saying my son was born with a midwife
not in the hospital and the pediatrician
told us that we needed to go we need to
get Social soci security to issue a
social security number and they would
say well he should have issued it but
that does happen sometimes so bring your
son in and we'll you know you can fill
out the paperwork we'll have one issued
you first we'll check to see he never
had one issued and if he hasn't we'll
issue one and so then it turned into my
son is out of the country and I need
this and then that turned into oh I'm
sorry well how old is he I was like um
you know he's three and they go well I'm
sorry if he's over the age of 12 months
old he has to come in hang up the phone
call back my son is 10 months old he's
out of the country born with a midwife
never had a social security number and
then they go oh okay that's fine just
get his birth certificate and a shot his
shot record and you can come in fill out
the paperwork we'll get issue you a
social security number and that's what I
did so I figured out how to create a
birth certificate you know I ordered the
security p paper you know when uh where
you make a copy it says you know void if
copied so I ordered had to order a bunch
of that and I went online and figured
out how to make a a fake birth
certificate it was great too cuz like
the county actually they give you a a
blank form and then they actually show
you what it looks like filled out like a
handwritten one filled out so I knew if
he was born this day he got these shots
uh two months later he got these shot 6
months later he got these shot so I just
filled it out I even had to order a a
seal so you have to have a seal that
says like Hillsboro County vital
statistics or Richland County vital
statistics or something and I couldn't
get anybody to make that so I changed it
to like Richland County Office of
virtual um records and then I took like
220 grit sandpaper and and and hit it
over and over and over again to wear it
down and then I State you know I did the
embossment on on the on the corner and
you know I printed it on the security
paper embossed it nobody looks at those
things you can see Richland County you
know you you could kind of see that and
really they just grab it and they go
like this this is what you realize after
you when I started getting started
getting uh driver's licenses issued by
uh by the State DMV right the state I I
figured out eventually it was easier to
just go into the DMV and have them give
me a a driver's license then actually
make one so but you notice they would
just grab the thing they feel the form
and go okay like they don't even look at
it so which is upsetting if you put as
much work into these documents as I am
for them to go okay yeah that's good sit
over there I felt like going like hey
bro like take a look at this this is
artwork yeah but they're looking for the
loow hanging fruit of crappy fraud right
yeah this stuff was right through so
okay so so birth certificate gets you a
uh Social Security number so it's
interesting because you've also you
you've done a lot of different
approaches to um creating synthetic
people there's homeless people involved
so sometimes it's grounded in real
people or real
names and then you're right like some
part is fake some part is real sometimes
and sometimes it's completely all fake
right cuz now I have the name I have the
social security number and what's great
is they mail you what's even better is
you get then you get to pick whatever
name you want M you know cuz when you
pick your child's name he doesn't even
have to have your last name you pick any
name so I would pick a name and i' just
say oh my wife's last name is this if it
they questioned it which they never did
but you know I've got a social security
number and then I would go apply for
credit cards and i' get denied of course
but they would all offer me a secured
credit card so I I'd then fill out the
secured credit card and i' send them
send the bank the money and they would
give me a secured credit card for $500
$300 1,000 whatever was and then once
you start making the
payments I pulled the credit and a
credit profile shows up saying that this
31y old man with a social security
number that I know was issued you know a
couple months ago has three three credit
cards they don't even say secure they
just say there's like this credit card
is $500 it was issued by Bank of America
this one was issued by Capital One this
one so I've got three of them but I had
no credit
scores so at that point I kind of kicked
back and waited and I just kept making
payments and I remember thinking to
myself I'll bet you they that the credit
bureaus don't generate credit scores for
at least a year and I was like God this
is going to be a year-long process and
while that was happening I started other
I was starting other ones because I
figured at least in a year I'll have a
bunch of these secur you know these um
we called them like Phantom borrowers
but now they call them synthetic
identities so at least I would have
these synthetic identities and maybe I
could do something with them but what
happened was at 6 months I went and I
randomly pulled the guy's credit you
know the person's credit and
705 credit scores 705 701 695 I was like
oh my go you only needed a 620 to borrow
to get a 95% loan from the bank so I was
like oh my God this is in this is
amazing sure enough a month later the
other ones had started all of them Bam
Bam Bam so what do you do with a phantom
borrower like what how do you make money
on this so I think most people if you
were just like a scammer a fraudster you
would you would probably just get credit
cards and maybe build up that history or
maybe try and borrow a personal loan uh
which is limited you know it's personal
loans are used to be you used to be you
could go
to uh an FDIC insured bank which borrows
money
those you know the personal loans they
lend out at the max $15,000 you know so
you could do that so you can go through
this whole process creating a fake
identity getting a card paying it off
building up credit and then you get
$155,000 at the end or so right you get
15 maybe you know if you want to keep
making the payments you know if you
could wait a year you could probably get
15,000 uh maybe you could maybe get 20
30,000 and a bunch of little smaller
ones you you get 77500 cuz I did I did
there was $7,500 from City Bank you know
$5,500 from American General so you
maybe get what $25,000 you know maybe
30,000 in personal loans maybe you can
you could you could then apply for you
give maybe get another 20 or 30,000 in
regular credit cards you know 10,000
here 8,000 5,000 and then you go to the
lower department store cards and you go
to Home Depot you get a th000 you get
500 so it ends up being maybe you can
get 50 60,000 maybe if you really good
you could get up to 80 or $100,000 in
credit cards and personal loans if you
really knew what you were doing but per
person per identity per identity but I
had the ability
to to leverage that perfect those
perfect credit profiles against
properties and I mean ultimately that's
what I end up doing and and so each one
of those identities was
worth you know a few million can you
explain how that works so uh to leverage
them against property so how does that
work with the mortgage so what I did
eventually I mean this would like is
down the road but you know I mean at
this point when things are just my whole
life had kind of gone off the The
Rails I was on federal probation and and
so what I did decided I was going to do
was start running a scam a much larger
scam and what I was going to do was it I
was going to start flipping properties
right like buy houses cheap fix them up
and sell them there's an area of Tampa
called eore
City so I was going to start flipping
houses in eor city and you know I
thought okay I can I can buy these
houses for you could buy a really crappy
house at that time for 50 $60,000 let's
say 50 and then you could put $25,000
into it in renovations you could
renovate it for 25 and maybe you could
get an appraisal for a
100 so thought what I could do is I
can I can buy these houses renovate them
and sell them to you know regular
people but I also had been working on
the synthetic identities and then I
thought well or I could just sell them
to synthetic identities and then I
wouldn't have to dump 25,000 into it
right and these guys are perfect they
have perfect credit I can provide W2s
and paystubs because by this point I'm
manufactur ing
businesses so I've got I've got I've
Incorporated businesses I've got
websites for the businesses W2s pay stub
so these guys have these guys look
perfect so I figured I'll buy these
properties for 50,000 sell it to these
guys for 100 maybe I'll pocket 40 or
50,000 I don't really have to do
anything but that seemed shortsighted so
I thought would be even better is that
if I did a little bit of Renovations and
then I sold it for much higher maybe I
put 10,000 clean the outside of it cuz
these guys don't care what the inside of
of the property looks like you know they
they're not they don't exist
so and then I but I can't how am I going
to get an appraisal for
$100,000 well do you you know how
appraisals work okay so the bank sends
an appraiser out or at that time you
could provide an appraisal they can
review it so they'll do what's called a
Desktop review they review it they
review it
on um on the computer they never go out
to the property or they send someone out
they they call that you know it's like a
field review they send someone out and
they just look at the house they don't
go in it though so I have to clean out
the clean up the outside of the house so
what I did was but the problem is is if
your hous is you're trying to sell that
house for let's say 200,000 the other
houses they have to pick three
comparable sales in the area that are
also going to support a a 200,000 dollar
sales price well there's no other houses
selling for 200,000 near this house so I
thought if I want to get these things
appraised for 200
250,000 I have to have comparable sales
and that appraisal is going to be
reviewed so what I did
was I started I went out and I bought
this house for
50,000
and I recorded the sale at2 200,000 000
So when you buy a house for $100,000 you
pay $700 in dock
stamps but if you pay the extra an extra
700 bucks the sale shows up for
$200,000 I'm buying these things for 50
so I'm paying $350 and I'm just paying
an extra
$1,00
50 so I'm so it ends up being you know
$1,400 but the but the sale shows up at
$200,000 on a house that's a a crack
house I bought for
$50,000 now I go I trim the trees we mow
the yard we clean up the porch we put a
porch rail on maybe we paint it real
nice we black out all the windows you
can't see inside um but from the from
the curb it looks great and I get an
appraisal so I do that with that house I
do that with another house all within a
mile so I buy four houses knowing I can
use the all there's a subject and three
comparables for all of them so the first
thing I did is I bought four four houses
for 50,000 60,000 40,000 and I recorded
the values at you know 210 200
190 so I get an appraiser to come out
there he appraises it he said of course
he says it's horrible but there's
comparables here now of course it is in
bad shape and he says it's in bad shape
but I I go ahead and I correct all that
so I correct it so now if you if you
review the appraisal and you're in
California or even if you drive your car
down the appraiser comes to the house
and looks at it from the street it looks
fine but the truth is I've got $60,000
into this property and you're appraising
it for 200,000 so the bank's rated not
they're not going to lend 200 but
they'll lend 190 so the bank is ready to
lend this synthetic
borrower $190,000 on a house that I have
60,000 in so I walk so I schedule a
closing
and we close on the house and I walk
away with
$60,000 you know and and the thing is
like the problem was is by the time I
got to this point I knew so many people
in the industry I nobody had to really
at that point show up although I've had
people show up for the synthetics and
sign for them almost all the closings
nobody ever showed up I just showed up
and said to the title uh to the title
agency and said hey my borrower he's at
work right now he can't make it can I
just take the file and I'll have him
sign all the documents at his work and
I'll bring them back he's like an hour
and a half away from here I'll be back
in two or three hours they're like oh
wow that man Matt thank you so much and
they would give it to me and I'd go sit
in the parking lot and I'd sign all the
documents and i' wait an hour or two and
I'd come back in and say here you go how
how are you able to keep all this in
your mind because you have to not slip
up in any of these conversations it's
pretty easy for me to for me to keep
them everything in the correct category
does that makes sense like it's it's I'm
not great at a lot of things but this I
was very good at but well there's these
Phantom people that exist and they were
becoming real people in your mind is
then like you're able to tell good
stories with with those people right
like because if you're talking to the
appraiser if you're talking to the
everybody in involved well keep in mind
the appraiser almost never meets the
borrower never not even like 99.99 99%
of the time they never meet him but you
have to talk about them yeah so I guess
what I'm asking is you're able to
converse fluently about these synthetic
identities yeah they they all had
different jobs they all had all the jobs
were basically they were all on the job
for five years they were all it was a
lot of it was there's a template yeah
exactly but I got it listen all matter
of fact almost every one of them had the
same birth date you know so because I
you know who knows um there's so it it
yeah it wasn't difficult and keep in
mind the a lot of the the Brokers barely
ever meet um meet the bar they call in
on the phone but it didn't matter anyway
because I'm walking and saying I got a
slam dunk deal for you and they're like
oh wow Matt you got the W2s the pce dubs
you've got all the you got all their uh
their rental history you have everything
done it's perfect thank you so much
they're happy to do it hey I print up
the docs and I'll have them go sign it
great wow thank you you know assuming
they didn't already know about it almost
everybody involved in this by the time I
was done was involved there was probably
15 or 20 people that all knew what was
going on the full of it they knew the
full depth of it yes yeah at yeah maybe
not 100% everything but they definitely
knew this is fraud and they were still
going along with it yeah yeah keep in
mind that even even when I give you an
example one of
my you know let's take and this happened
with almost all of them was he would buy
five
houses so the guy B what happens the
basic design was I buy the
houses I record the values
higher
and this person buys all five houses
refinances them he ends up borrowing a
little bit over a million dollar in his
name uh then of course then I go and I I
get um personal loans from several Banks
I get credit cards I run up all of his
credit cards by this point I've got 10
$20,000 worth of credit cards in the
guy's name so the guys are all worth
like a million million and change well
once I stop paying you start getting
letters from the collection companies
right from the banks you know then they
sell them off so after about three
months you're getting tons of letters
and what I would do is
I would take my borrower's name I would
go online and I would find or i' go in
the newspaper and I would
find I would find an article about let's
say like a 12C car pile up you know so
there's you know there a huge accident
on I4 it's very dangerous so there's a
12C car pile up and someone in the
accident was life flighted to Tampa
General
hospital I
would cut and paste that
article and I would just insert my
borrower's name into the article saying
that you know Brandon green was LIF
flighted to Tampa General Hospital is
currently in critical condition I would
then print that article out on newsprint
I then make a copy of the cut it up make
copy of the newsprint Highlight his name
and I would write a letter from Brandon
Green's fictional sister to the
collection companies saying several
months ago my brother was in a horrible
car accident he is currently they've got
the article they have the highlighted
name he clearly was in in this uh in
this accident he is currently in a coma
and the doctors say even if he wakes up
from the coma he will never work again
that you know so you might as well just
foreclose on stop writing us letters and
take the houses back and that's all
they're looking for is is is a reason at
this point even if they look into
Brandon green they can't figure out if
he's a real person or not
because he's got a social security
number he's got and everything went bad
at the same time he's got multiple
rental properties or his primary
residence all of his credit cards went
bad everything went bad we have an
excuse we have a letter that happens
people get divorced they lose their job
they get in accidents it's reasonable
when they look into it all looks
legitimate even if they ordered another
appraisal by this point it's not four
comparable sales or three or four
comparable sales by this point it's like
10 15 20 30 4 4050 cuz I kept making
more and more of these guys what was
your just a almost like a tangent what's
your thinking process there's a lot of
cleverness going on here so like uh the
the car pileup as a solution newspaper
and you mail
it are you sitting there alone and
thinking through this like how do you
come up with that idea it's a it's a
very interesting a very clever
Innovative idea so at first I I thought
about making like a a fake death
certificate mhm he died you know but I
thought I don't know like what if you
know like some of these places had like
you know uh you know primary mortgage
insurance like what if the primary
mortgage insurance like what if they try
and claim because he was dead or like I
don't know I don't know that side so I'm
like I don't want to do that I want to
do something that's semi verifiable and
third parties it's like a third party
telling you this is what happened I
thought well like the newspaper you know
and you know or do I claim bankruptcy
and I've done that I've gone and got the
bankruptcy forms right you can go to the
bankruptcy court and they'll give you
forms to mail to all of your uh
creditors and you mail them they stop
contacting they wait to be no located by
or notified by the bankruptcy court but
my fear there is you know uh nobody's
ever going to notify them like I'm not
going through bankruptcy for one of
these guys so it was like this is the
this is a better bet than just writing a
letter saying I'm going through a
divorce my wife's keeping those houses
that's her problem you know you could do
there's lots of things you could do but
to me this was they're not going to try
and how do you how do you shut it down
without him dying how do you shut that
down this is how you shut it down he's
in a coma he'll never work again he was
in a car accident here's the proof he
can't even write you I'm his sister I
wrote you the letter it's a one-time
letter that seems to um tie up all
exactly
exactly you know I can only know the ex
exactly how that you know what sparked
that is as much as there were so many
other avenues that I could have gone
that I was I just didn't know I was you
were thinking through all those
different Avenues yeah are you mostly
thinking
alone I mean you know I had guys I was
bouncing ideas ideas off of there were
other guys that were involved in the
scam you know everybody I think that
scam ended up making like I think the
FBI said it was like 11 and a half
million or something and and you know
but but there were so many other people
that were involved in that scam that
were you know this guy's getting 50 this
guy's getting 20 you know 177,000 20,000
25,000 and you know the we're just doing
it constantly and so the bank would
foreclose on that property they' take it
back they put it back on the MLS they
put it back on the MLS for 100 for
200,000 it wouldn't sell then they drop
it to you know 150 wouldn't sell then
they drop it to 125 130 wouldn't sell
they drop it to 90 and somebody buy it
for like 90 wasn't worth 90 but by that
point that whole area had we' done so
many houses at that point the whole area
shot up and the the FBI said uh we did
109 houses I don't think that's true
but wow we we when I end up leaving
Tampa after that scam falls apart and
the FBI shows up Forbes came out with an
article whatever six months later and
they
said that the ebore city zip code was
one of the top 20 fastest growing z um
appraising areas in the country and you
know everybody was like oh that's mad
cuz this place is a dump like this is is
a horrible place like this is and I
remember one time I had talked to a guy
you know years later and he was like ah
all the comparable sales have dried up
like when you left there was just
nothing even close to
200,000